it's been a rough rough year you know
craig's our boss played against cliff a
lot
loud olson was my neighbor in arizona so
i'm a lot great guy last time i talked
to him
he was getting advice on what kind of
dog to get uh
and i set him up with my my handler and
then obviously chad was
just on the show a few months ago and
when i started reading about he had been
battling colon cancer for four years i'm
like no idea
yo man this dude was working and doing
all this stuff
with class and dignity and he was the
most humble
guy and i'm like the hair that in the
back of your mind and still
doing all your tv stuff that it takes a
strong
man my thoughts and prayers are with all
those
all all those affected and man when
somebody dies in the nba it's like part
of our family so
the robinson family and the olsen family
the berry family and the boswick family
man just
just thank thank you for sharing those
people with us
uh my condolences goes out to all those
family
cliff and derek coleman were some of the
toughest guys i had to play against the
reason why because they played five
but on offense they played the four so
i'd have to go out and guard them so i
can remember cliff saying shaq i know
you're gonna score on me but now you got
to bring your big ass out to the
three-point line
so you know he was wonderful and you
know chadwick
you know even though i'm i am who i am
it's it's an honor for me to meet other
superstars you know playing in la that
would make my day just seeing superstars
and
you know when i finally met mr black
panther he was nice
like charles said you know he was humble
i never met
craig's dad so craig uh my condolences
to your family but
has been a very tough year the worst
year of my life
i lost a lot of people also lost some
people during covet
and you know we just have to continue to
uh
move forward and hopefully it'll it'll
get better but
i wish 2020 was gone oh yeah well
condolences to all the families um
you know obviously we've all known cliff
a little bit closer
at times because we were competitors uh
with him uh he's from
you know went to uconn connecticut you
know so i you know we know a lot about
cliff
and the condolences of the family but
over the last year i became
really closer to chadwick because when
he came on his show
uh we were talking and he just was like
can i need a favor from you he's like
what i need you to take my dad
to a carolina we're the biggest chapel
hill carolina fans you know
and we just started talking about tar
heel stories and so we just became
really good friends and then as we saw
last week
he was in that tribute that we did for
kobe bryant which is was eerie that i
had him pose in an iconic
picture the way um the actual kobe had
done
after winning and so i'm actually
shooting that
and uh one of the last things he was
talking about my son at north carolina
but then
then about a month ago he sent me a
26-page letter
through email that he said he was
sending to all of his
family members and he said kenny you
should do this with your
family and it's a it's called grocery
list and it was about
which how you should live how you should
eat how you should take care of yourself
and take care of your bodies and so he
and he was good and he's actually
for all his family members who want it
he was actually going to pay for them to
do that
if they wanted him to do it and so
that's when the humility and
all of those things thought never
watched chuck mentioned in
i'm going through cancer not once no not
one time you know i talked to the guy
you know multiple times it never
happened so just um
unbelievable and lastly i know shaky
said you know
i wish 2020 i love 2020 because it is
um it made me more aware how much people
how much i love people
you have never said you love me more
every time we get off the phone love you
bro you never did that before
my kids stayed in my house for four
months
we talked about things we never did
before like
so business-wise start adventures jet
academy all these different
that i've never done before so as much
as 2020
and social injustice speaking out
getting opportunities like this
as much as there is bad i'm happy that
20 20
brought that out of me no magic words at
a uh
at a time like this to relieve the pain
that these families are
feeling the olsens and the bozemans and
the
robinsons and the berry family just
prayers for you all for comfort and
strength and peace